I got some celebrity tax related news
I'd love to hear it oh thank you that's
all I got I wasn't going to continue if
you hadn't said that this is true story
Mike the situation Sorrentino from
jersey shore remember him yeah well you
don't have to answer Mike the situation
Sorrentino from jersey shore is facing
up to 15 years in prison on tax evasion
charges tax evasion yeah so basically if
you're a reality star in this country
you don't pay your taxes we either put
you in prison or make you president
so wide that's a wide chasm of choice
prison white house alright big story in
politics right now bill o'reilly under
fire yeah
Fox News Fox News said it will
investigate multiple accusations against
Bill O'Reilly for sexually harassing
female co-workers yeah apparently four
years old I li has been telling female
co-workers their breasts are fair and
balanced
[Applause]
thank you thank you very much thank you
this show costs you nothing by the way
totally free
Russia Russia has banned any images of
Vladimir Putin photoshopped to make it
look like he's in drag is illegal yeah
authorities in Russia said Putin
shirtless on a horse is plenty gay
enough
he's always like that he's got his this
is kind of justing a Turkish airline
crew a Turkish airline crew helped
deliver a baby on board a flight and
then in keeping with the times the baby
was dragged from the plane by security
was overbooked what did you do get out
of here baby I was going on sports news
today former NFL player Titus young was
sentenced to four years in prison Young
said he's sad to go to prison but happy
to be reunited with his old teammates
that's nice one guy was yay-yay crime
there's a new campaign to create the
world's first vagina museum vagina
museum yeah yes the vagina museum will
be the first museum where you enter
through the gift shop a lot of people
cheered that one without really getting
it just happy to have that topic crazy a
package of salad mix a package of salad
mix that was sold in a Florida Walmart
was found to contain a dead bat this is
shocking news shocking news someone
shopping at Walmart bought a salad
[Applause]
you